CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
Hi everyone.
Welcome back to Google
Developers Live.
My name is Claudio and I am one
of the engineers in the
Google Drive Developer
Relations Team.
Today with me I have two special
guests, Austin and
Sebastian from Cooliris.
Austin is the co-founder
and CTO of Cooliris.
And Sebastian works on Business
Development, is that right?
SEBASTIAN MUEHL: Exactly.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Today they're
going to show us their
app, Cooliris, which is, I would
say, visually stunning.
It's an amazing way to browse
your photos and do a lot of
other things.
And I am pretty sure they can
explain it and show it much
better than I could do.
Austin, do you want to
show us what Cooliris
does and what it is?
AUSTIN SHOEMAKER: I'd love to.
So Cooliris is an app for mobile
devices and the web,
which allows you to organize and
view all your media in a
unified experience, which allows
you to first access the
media on your device.
So here I'm accessing all
of the photos that are
stored on my tablet.
All visible in this user
interface we've created that
we call the Wall.
So the Wall actually allows me
to see everything and zoom
into it and see the high
resolution content without the
need to leave the grid of
photos that I'm in.
So that makes it much easier for
me to just come and zoom
in and see one photo without
having to keep pressing the
back button in the top left.
So I can browse content
from my camera roll.
And I can also link all of the
web services that I'm using.
So for example, we support
your device, Facebook,
Instagram, Twitter, Picasa,
Google+, Google Drive, Flickr.
And we just introduced
support for Renren
in China and SmugMug.
You can also search Google
Images to find images.
And one of the big features that
you can take advantage of
in Cooliris is sharing any media
that you can browse with
private groups.
So that enables you to start a
conversation around anything
that you see.
And more than that, integrating
Google Drive has
enabled us to let you save
content from anywhere into
your Drive, which provides a
really great bridge between
your mobile device and
your computer.
So let me jump into Google Drive
and show you what that
looks like.
So all I do is tap on that
stack of photos.
And I'm already looking at all
of the media in my Drive.
So when we looked at, how do
we want to integrate Drive,
we're a very media-centric
experience, and so what we've
done is use the Google Drive
API to show you your photos
that are stored in Drive in
reverse chronological order.
So these are the latest
photos that have
been added to my Drive.
And as I scroll, we actually
allow you to scroll through
all of the media that's
stored in Drive.
And if I select a photo, it
actually will load the high
resolution version
of this photo.
But that's where it starts to
become really cool that we're
able to take advantage
of the Drive API.
So these images might be very
large JPEGs, or even more
large files like RAW.
Since Google Drive indexes
thumbnails, we're actually
able to request not only a small
thumbnail of the photo,
which allows us to go through
the grid very quickly, but we
can also load the exact high
resolution representation
that's needed to display
it on your device.
So instead of loading a three or
four megabyte JPEG, we can
actually load exactly 300
kilobytes, which is enough to
show it on your--
And one of the really cool
things that we're able to do
is keep this up-to-date.
So the APIs that we're using to
populate the user interface
are the Drive files API, which
we use to pull in the files
sorted by a date modified.
And once we've loaded the
initial pages of files from
the files.get API, we then,
instead of refreshing that,
will pull the changes feed,
which gives us an ordered set
of changes to files that
are in your Drive.
And by using files.get to
paginate out as you scroll
backward, and also using changes
list in order to get
the updates that have occurred
to what we've loaded, that
makes it very efficient for us
to show you a updated view of
content from your Drive
without pulling
everything up front.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So you're
using a number tricks here to
have this very fast browsing
experience.
So all already to
the Drive API.
First, you're downloading the
whole set the very first time,
but then using the changes
feed to only get changes.
And--
[TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES]
AUSTIN SHOEMAKER: --in
that conversation.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
That's very nice.
Thank you.
So I think my first question
when I saw that is, I said,
this is beautiful, and
unfortunately, I
do not have an iPad.
But I work at Google and I have
some Android devices.
Any plans to have Cooliris
on Android?
AUSTIN SHOEMAKER: So it's very
exciting that we can say we're
actively building our
Android application.
So the next major release of
Cooliris is 3.0, and that will
be fully supported on
iOS and Android.
And we think this is really
important because people who
are using this app to
communicate and share with
each other want everyone
to be able to
interact with each other.
So we don't really have a
complete communication product
until everybody can
actively engage.
And we're very excited about the
latest platform features
in Android and plan to take full
advantage of them when we
release our product.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So let's say
I have Android device and
you have an iPad, and we both
use Cooliris, can we do
whatever you just did with
conversation and share
everything?
Doesn't matter what device
I use, right?
AUSTIN SHOEMAKER: Exactly, so
same experience across devices
and the web.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Cool.
That's awesome.
Can I ask you how many
users you have?
SEBASTIAN MUEHL: Yeah,
right now, we
see 2.3 million installs.
So we just launched
in July 2012.
And I think this is a very
good head start.
We also see 350 million photos
viewed, which is an amazing
number, I think.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Nice,
good job guys.
So you said what's coming
next, that's very good.
You also mentioned some of the
features we are working on,
like push notifications.
At Google we are working
on adding these kind of
notifications to the Google
Drive API, which is also going
to help you.
Can you talk a bit more about
your experience with the
Google Drive API?
I mean, you're using a
lot of cool things,
like advanced features.
Was there anything you
didn't find as good?
AUSTIN SHOEMAKER: Using
Google Drive?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Maybe you
couldn't find anything bad,
but maybe you did.
AUSTIN SHOEMAKER: Oh, so when
we first integrated with the
version two API, which was the
first time we could really
build our product.
In the version one API, you were
only able to store and
get files created by
the application.
And in the version two API we're
able to request access
to all the files that are on
Drive, which is what we were
able to build the Wall with.
There's no image centric
metadata.
And that's one of the things
that the Drive--
other image metadata, which
we're able to display in the
little metadata bar
at the bottom.
And there's no way that we could
actually display that to
you without API assistance
because we'd
have to load the files.
So the beautiful thing here is
that Drive API can stream us
the content that we need.
First, the metadata, and then
the low resolution thumbnail,
and then, on demand, the high
resolution content.
It was initially a limitation,
and then it was quickly
addressed in the API.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: You mentioned
the image metadata.
When we released the first
version API we got a lot of
requests about adding more
and more metadata to the
image and we did.
We added some of the
common Exif fields.
So what fields do you
actually surface?
I see you use file name,
and the file size,
and width and height.
Do you also use other fields,
like location or what camera
took that photo, things
like that?
Are those needed?
AUSTIN SHOEMAKER: Yeah, so
right now, we don't show
extended Exif metadata, like
camera make, model, et cetera.
We'll probably add that
in the future.
One of the ones we do use
today is location,
which is very cool.
So if your photo has geographic
coordinates, then
we get that information from
the Drive API and then we
reverse geocode that into a
named location, which we
display in the metadata bar
when you select the photo.
So that's really great because
then you can get more context
for your media.
Instead of just seeing the
photo, you can see when and
where it was taken.
One feature that Drive
has always had--
which is really cool and that
makes us look even more cool,
although it's purely the
API doing this, I'd
love to show you--
content based search.
So all of the photos that you
add to Drive are instantly
indexed by Drive to extract
landmarks, objects, and other
recognizable searchable terms.
So I've put a whole bunch of
photos in here and I want to
go look for some photos
of the Eiffel Tower
that I remember taking.
So all I have to do is
actually search--
you can't probably--
--the next feature requests.
I would absolutely love
to build on that.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah, I mean,
this is another common
feature request we got.
You're not the only ones
asking for this.
We think that the Google Goggles
integration-- which is
what you just showed-- is one
of the very cool features of
Google Drive.
So anyone can just go to Drive,
even without the API,
go to their Drive account on the
web, search for things, as
you just did looking for
Germany, and see things that
are related to that.
Because we recognize the image
and that's super cool.
I think we are probably the only
ones having that, which
is amazing.
And we're still debating how
to expose that information
through the API.
We will definitely talk
more about that.
Yeah, that's a great request
and it's a common one.
So good job with that.
And we will probably
do something.
OK, cool.
Yeah, I think that's
it with Cooliris.
That was an awesome
description of the
application, and how this
actually works, and all the
APIs it uses, and all the tricks
these guys have used to
make things fast
and beautiful.
And my takeaway is that I'm
really looking forward for the
Android version.
You don't want to say anything
about dates, right?
AUSTIN SHOEMAKER: Not
yet, but we will
definitely keep you posted.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK, cool.
With that, I would say
thank you guys again.
Thank you for joining me.
And I will see all of you next
time we go live, that is next
Tuesday at 11 AM.
Thank you very much and see
you next time on Google
Developers Live.